Wendy where the hell are the flying
cars we want flys yeah it's not an easy
problem to solve there needs to be
available infrastructure so we able
these things take off and land there
needs to be air traffic management that
will control these things and we haven't
even really figured it out with the cars
on the ground yeah 35,000 people die
every year from car accidents on on the
ground and these aren't cars falling out
of the sky right right how heavy do your
batteries need to be to fly you know
from point A to point B and maintain a
charge very heavy so there's a lot that
will go into that from the technology
design standpoint and from the
infrastructure and regulations
perspective do you foresee that is that
is that a real future is it happening
tomorrow no but I foresee it I foresee
that it will happen